police along the East Coast are
searching for a Florida teenager who may
have run away with a soccer coach at her
high school investigators believe that
17 year old Katelyn Rosina is with 27
year old Ryan Rodriguez police say that
the teenagers snuck out through her
bedroom window Michelle Miller is
tracking the search and it's now in its
fourth day Michelle good morning good
we're hearing a lot a lot of worried
relatives all over good morning Florida
officials have issued a missing child
alert and police believe the pair are
heading toward the Northeast or even
across the border into Canada where
Rodriguez has family back in Florida
Kaitlyn's family is urging her to return
home let somebody know that you're safe
we miss you pumpkin and we love you and
we want to hear from you
Scarlett frissina made a tearful plea to
her daughter Katelyn who police say ran
away with Ryan Rodriguez someone the
family considered a friend Kaitlyn's
father Ward helped Rodriguez get a job
as an assistant soccer coach at the high
school I texted him first thing that
morning hey have you heard anything have
you talked to anybody that knows and I
haven't heard anything when I call his
phone it goes to I can't get ahold of
him during the initial search for
Kaitlyn
police discovered Rodriguez was missing
too and a text message from Kaitlyn to
her friend indicated there may have been
a relationship between the two the teen
wiped her cell phone and left it behind
but took some clothing and her wallet
the pair was last seen on Sunday using
an ATM at this gas station in st. Marys
Georgia Kaitlyn stopped and used her
debit card to get $200 in cash and at
that time of course all of that video
and they were both seen on video at that
time police are on the lookout for
Rodriguez's red mercury sable with a
Florida license plate we don't want her
out there in this world without her
parents she needs to be home so our
concern is that she may face issues or
dangers out there that she's not
equipped to handle the Columbia County
School District released a statement
saying it has suspended Rodriguez from
his position as the coach of the boys
soccer team and is cooperating with
authorities and whether or not
Rodrigues faces charges could depend on
the nature of his relationship with
frizz inna right now they are not
considering this a kidnapping case you
have a different kind of betrayal for
that family and they're 17 you think you
know a lot you really don't know
anything at 17 especially when you're
involved with an older guy well no clue
yeah no clue when the clock is certainly
ticking I'm sure that we're gonna catch
the night yeah Michelle thank you very
much thank you